okay here's an Iran and in the upper
left-hand corner you can see the impulse
is traveling down the neuron it's down
the axon and you know let's go ahead and
pause let's go ahead and pause that
impulse right there and let's zoom on in
and take a closer look okay now that
we've zoomed on in remind yourself the
interior of a neuron has a negative
charge
I know it might look in the picture
might look in the picture like the
inside is positive because of all of the
positive potassium I just didn't draw
all the negative the negative proteins
that are inside of a neuron I didn't
want to add too much clutter but please
remind yourself the internal is a
negative charge and so what happens
during an action potential is it says
that around the charge of negative 40
millivolts watch the two black doorways
on the left the two black doorways on
the left are going to open these black
doorways represent what are called
sodium channels a channel is simply a
passageway and the sodium channels
respond and and open around negative 40
millivolts and when that happens now
that the sodium channels are our open
sodium will simply rapidly diffuse to
the inside of the neuron remember the
inside of a neuron is negatively charged
normally but because of all the positive
sodium's that just entered the charged
rushes up from negative all the way up
to positive 50 millivolts that's the
impulse the impulse is that change from
negative to positive remember an impulse
is simply an electrical charge an
impulse is that change from negative to
positive
well like the notes say around positive
50 millivolts the black sodium channels
will close and the red potassium
channels will open and what happens next
is the red potassium will diffuse out of
the cell dropping the charge all the way
down to negative 90 when the charge was
positive 50 at the start but then a
bunch of positive potassium exited the
cell internally lost its positive charge
dropped all the way down to negative 90
and like the notes say around negative
90 the sodium
excuse me around negative 90 the red
potassium channels will close and the
the black sodium channels were open
actually the the sodium channel is open
around negative 40 no of millivolts but
because the potassium is exiting so
rapidly the charge continues down all
the way to negative 90 and so now that
the next set of sodium channels are
opened we repeat what happens next is
the sodium will rapidly diffuse bringing
the charge from negative 90 all the way
up to positive 50 again again that's the
impulse the change from negative to
positive to negative to positive and so
on and just like last time when the
charge reaches positive 50 the sodium
channel the black sodium channels are
gonna close the red potassium channels
are gonna open and remember right now
the internal charge is positive 50 but
when all those potassium Zechs --it it's
gonna lose the positive charge it's
gonna drop all the way down to negative
90 negative 90 millivolts and just like
happened last time around negative 90
millivolts the red potassium channels
closed and around negative 40 millivolts
the next set of black sodium channels
are gonna open the charge continues to
drop however because the sodium excuse
me because the potassium is exiting so
rapidly so when the charge reaches
negative 90 that's when the the red
potassium channels closed well let's
focus our eyes on the the last set of
doors on the right now that the black
sodium channels are open we simply
repeat a bunch of positively charged
sodium ions diffuse on in bringing the
charge all the way up to positive 50
millivolts that's again the impulse the
change from negative to positive to
negative to positive well we simply
repeat around positive 50 millivolts the
the sodium channels closed and the
potassium channels open and I hope you
know what happens next the potassium
exits dropping the charge all the way
down the negative 90
we simply have repeated the process
several times in this animation and
around negative 90 the potassium
channels closed the next set of sodium
channels would open and the process
would simply keep repeating
so here is another animation this one's
a little more simplistic there's not so
much clutter so hopefully this is a
little more clear if you thought the
last one was a little hard to follow so
again I want to remind you that even
though there's some positive potassium
is on the inside of the cell the
overwhelming internal charge of a cell
of a neuron of a neuron is a negative
charge and watch what happens this is
this animation only takes maybe 10
seconds watch what happens when the
sodium channel opens the area becomes
quickly positive but that positive
charge only lasts for a split moment
once the charge becomes positive that
will stimulate the opening of a
potassium channel and the potassium
exits and that's what an action
potential is it's that change from
positive to negative to positive to
negative all the way down the length of
a neuron so go ahead and rewind the
video if you want to see that again I
think that's a real clean helpful
animation for you
when we come back to the animation I
added a few things I added these blue
triangular shaped objects I I didn't
want them in the previous animation
because I didn't want them to add
clutter but pretend that they were
actually there in the previous animation
I just didn't want them to be to be in
the way of the previous animation watch
what they do now you have this big mess
of sodium that rushed into the cell and
this big mess of potassium that exited
the cell look what the sodium potassium
pump does three sodium's at a time will
be pumped out of the cell and two
potassium at a time will be pumped back
into the cell it's reloading the cell
it's basically putting the cell back to
normal and the same thing happens with
the other ones three sodium's at a time
are pumped out and two potassium at a
time are pumped in so you can imagine if
all these sodium pumps were working
there's six of them in the animation if
they were all working at the same time
they would restore the cell back to
normal in a very short amount of time
once the cell was restored back to
normal it's able to send another impulse
so here we have our diagram that we saw
earlier let's watch the animation as the
impulse travels eventually it comes to
the tips or the terminals let's zoom on
into the terminals and take a closer
look
okay now that we've zoomed on in again
here we have the end of a neuron on the
left the terminal end on the left and
the beginning of a neuron on the right
the dendrite of a neuron on the right
and like the note says an impulse will
reach the axons terminal watch the
animation sodium channels open the
positive charge is created potassium
exits and just like we saw a moment ago
sodium rushes in potassium rushes out
but now in the animation the impulse has
reached the terminal end well you notice
how there is a bluish round circle that
represents a cell part known as a
vesicle and so the vesicle is going to
fuse with the cell membrane and release
those orange circles that it was
protecting those orange circles
represent chemical messenger molecules
called neuro transmitters watch the
animation
the animation says that those orange
neurotransmitters are going to diffuse
across that gap that gap is called the
synapse and they're gonna attach
themselves they're gonna land they're
gonna be caught by what are called
receptors there are receptors on the
neighboring neuron dendrites have
receptors on there at their tips like
you see in the picture and like it also
says in the animation when excuse me
when the neurotransmitters land on the
receptors look what it causes them to do
look at the top of of the of the
dendrite on the right look what happens
one of the sodium channels is gonna open
so when the when the neurotransmitters
land on the receptors that causes the
charge inside of the neuron to reach
negative 40 and like we saw a moment ago
at negative 40 the black sodium channels
open and I hope you see what's gonna
happen next
sodium will rush on in and then
potassium rushes out so the new impulse
is created so the impulse from the
neuron to the left caused
neurotransmitters to be released across
the synapse and when the
neurotransmitters landed on the neuron
to the right it caused the neuron on the
right to create a brand new impulse